Well, there's a new horror movie trailer out
for the first time in a while, so just for
old times' sake: if you want to hear the meaning
behind this, then stick around to the end
of this video.
Freaky is the new horror comedy from director
Christopher Landon, who is probably most known
for making the Happy Death Day movies.
This is kind of a perfect project for him,
because Happy Death Day is basically Groundhog
Day if it had a serial killer, and Freaky
is basically Freaky Friday if it had a serial
killer.
"OK, so I was never the most popular."
"Homecoming's this weekend."
"Booker is gonna be at the dance."
"And boys never really noticed me."
Wait what?
I don't buy that for a second.
We're talking about Kathryn Newton here.
We're talking about Lucy Stephens herself.
She’s cute as hell.
Interesting fact by the way, her and the director
Christopher Landon are both alumni of the
Paranormal Activity franchise...
Yeah, you're right, that's not interesting.
But I do have to give the director points
implementing creative and creepy school mascots
in his movies.
Showing off a little bit of his directorial
trademark there.
And also having clever slogans for those teams.
But the big homage here, other than Freaky
Friday and Happy Death Day is seen in this
part, where the killer chases down the girl
with some kind of magically activated knife,
and suddenly stormy clouds and lightning fill
the skies as some kind of ritual is performed,
the result of which is the killer's soul being
transferred into the girl and vice versa.
The theatrics are almost exactly the same
as what's seen in Child's Play, which also
features a serial killer using a ritual to
transfer his soul into another body, albeit
a much stubbier one.
In Child's Play, the killer discovers he has
a limited amount of time to transfer his soul
back into a human vessel before he gets stuck
inside the doll forever, and it seems like
Freaky follows similar rules.
"I have like less than six hours to swap back
or I'm gonna be stuck in this body forever."
I also noticed that the killer, who is known
as the Blissview Butcher, wears a mask.
It looks like a Redead Mask from The Legend
of Zelda: Ocarina of Time, which is closely
related to something called the Gibdo Mask,
which allows you to blend in with Redeads
and Gibdos undetected, just as the Blissview
Butcher can blend in with his victims undetected
while inside Millie's body.
Maybe there will be a scene where she does
the same thing and uses her new body to slide
in with criminals, just like Link uses various
masks to gain access to places in Majora's
Mask.
It also bears a pretty close resemblance to
the Jason mask from Friday the 13th.
In any event, even if that's not an intentional
reference, I do remember Christopher Landon
saying he wanted to bring back the idea of
the masked killer with Happy Death Day, and
with that series potentially dead, no pun
intended, it's good to see him continuing
it in another form.
Pun intended that time.
Cause Millie takes on another form...
Don't know what's going on here, but yeah,
that's the end of the trailer.
Friday the 13th because that's the spooky
day.
But let's be real, this things not gonna be
in theaters in November.
My theory is that movie studios keep putting
release dates in the pandemic, because when
that date comes and they inevitably have to
delay it, people report on it and they get
free press.
That being said, I wouldn't mind watching
this on my TV in November, but we'll see what
happens.
Click the video on the left to see my Things You Missed episode on Happy Death Day,
If you love horror subscribe to this channel
right now.
I'm not asking.
I've got new horrors every week, so ring that
deathbell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next one, assuming we stay inside.